also wir tragen ein nike max kelly
sebastian und wir spielen jetzt einfach
ganz klassisch piccolo es manchmal nicht
kennt ist auch keine produktplatzierung
untersucht einfach ein trinkspiel fürs
handy
nicht wir spielen wir spielen so als
würde niemand zuschauen also letzte
entwerte gibt kelly einen kurs oder sie
bringt zwei stücke okay zumal zwei fälle
die nächste person der nun die augen
siehst muss vier stücke trinken gibt um
das sich augen zu sehen
aber das geht ja noch weiter also wir
spielen jetzt mal weiteren
wirtschaftlichen dann die augen zu
gucken muss die personen vier stücke
sebastian verteilt so viele stücke wie
der berühmte maler aufzählen kann ich
höre auf wenn du willst aber du
verlierst du trinkst drei stücke beim
ersten fehler berühmte maler michael j
manet monet matisse mondrian renoir
picasso vorwort des berichts noch gar
nichts sagen
mal gucken ja okay das fünfte gebot
wir machen hier keine halben sachen du
darfst du wieder erzählt hat und dass
ihr davon träumt braucht ja hier weil
ich finde so unfassbar laut mag es wenn
schon mal mit kelly eine party
vorbereitet hast verteilt zwei stücke
ansonsten trägt sie selbst eine richtige
party nicht nennen glaub da führt kein
weg vorbei ich muss trinken mag es wäre
etwas was du nicht magst alles spieler
die das mögen dringend zwei stücke wenn
jemand trinkt trinkt
ok ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen sex
mit männern
das ist gar nichts mehr auch immer
schlauer
so müsst ihr im 50 trinken und wir
wissen natürlich nie okay macht einen
anderen spielern wer zuerst herausfindet
wer es ist bringt drei stücke ich kann
heute normalerweise scheiße du bist du
selbst sowieso wasser direkt linke
stimmen hat mich komplett julius
angeguckt und hat sie gesagt so
vielleicht würdest du einen freund
finden könnten 15 team was ich weiß ist
das ist so krass dass ich sagen sonst
wird die partei so viele stücke wie es
singles an diesem tisch geht am morgen
da wirkte verteilt ich kann hier
verteilen
sie das sehen theoretische perioden der
schweine gleichzeitig single immer nach
christus ist das nicht seitdem wir
sieglos sind aber dieser fliegt los mann
war ihr max herrmann tier beziehung
nehme deswegen halt machst du weiß halt
nie in szene
also halt bis zwölf jahren hatten wir
das gemacht hat das war ich habe mich
motivieren
also ich meine ich jahre und sagte dass
wir nicht mehr zusammen war das war dann
bestimmt
aber das hat in der vergangenheit schon
mal zu problemen geführt sondern würden
wir beide das gleiche wie ich bin und
nicht bekommst dann halt immer und der
krieg die vier stücke etwas total wie du
willst
sebastian krieg alle vier mike i do muss
entscheiden wenn kelly und magst du den
nächsten hunger games eingeladen werden
er hat seiner meinung nach die meisten
überlebenschancen katniss everdeen
körper drei stücke er ist mehr
überlebenskünstler kalium mir ich würde
sagen du aber nach was kelly alles
durchmachen musste fröhlichen bis 11 ich
glaube verließen nach punkt angekommen
wo sie einfach alles scheiße bedient
jetzt da mal die kirche jetzt ist dieser
schritt mehr
ich wäre selbst verstecken und fallen
warum ich würde zuerst mal zehn
verbündete suchen für die kochen
ich würde ich mir gesprochen und dann am
ende sind wir so wie wir - so zu 5 und
ich koche für die 4
und vergiftet dass dinge guck mal ich
glaub kennys law the pitch in letzter
zeit geworden ich glaube das ist kelly
wird mehr überleben was ich ihn kennt
mich hat länger ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob du bist so diese weise tipps
vermittelt
ich glaube die wird überleben
okay das ist eine tagung der
heiligengraber wird ist schön weil er
schon mal aber die haare jetzt geht's
los leute wahrheit oder pflicht spielt
einmal im kreis jeder stellt seinem
rechten nachbarn die frage zwei stücke
wenn der sich weigert max beginnt okay
okay das ist eine gute frage
ok ok welche personen aus unserem
gemeinsamen bekanntenkreis
zusammenfließen
du kannst auch brücke mit welcher
youtuber print würdest du niemals
schlafen und doppelte schon für die
frage ist wie es ist ich weiß was man
haben wenn die beantragten transport
shane ein statement es gibt ein bergdorf
benutzen kannst deinen freund nicht
einfach so was dürfen nicht vergeben
sein oder aber du kannst mich ergeben
weil er es zählt nicht angehoben weil
die freund hat ein besseres minister
heja dass der folge mega einfach nicht
genug davon haben mit dürfen von denen
seien aber ist darf mich der grund sein
weshalb du nicht okay bekommen
das würde die klage könnte ich mir über
die lustig machen ich hab mir gedacht
habe so viel praktischer ist einfach ja
sagen aber es hat einen freund ja
natürlich aber es ist ja nicht der
ausschlaggebende grund glaubst also ich
würde niemals mit jana bei die mit max
zusammen
ok jetzt musst du einmal gibt ok
erfolgen bei fly anderen ist denn das
ist er ist eine doppel frage aber
konkret zu beantworten welchen youtuber
der sie nicht hat würdest du eine
millionen abonnenten geben und welchen
der sie hattest du sie nehmen so viele
also die personen liessen nicht halten
würde
michael übergeben einen service aus
haben hier aus schwierig wie ein
indirektes die das ist so ein bisschen
support an geht über die cool sind wird
dann würde es mir selbst ich würde auf
jeden fall werde ich jemand anders wäre
vanessa hat nämlich die ist halt laboren
entertainer jan und wen würde ich nehme
mit so vielen ich kann ja nicht meinen
normalen agenda benutzen wobei ich diese
person nicht mag wen finde ich hat es
nicht verdient
ja okay dann ist zum leiter sie denn ich
kenne ich finde das ziemlich blöde ein
lieber das für dich vielleicht mal
belogen pause nicht vorkommen hat ja ja
so hast du nur noch eine frage an mich
mal geht also erstmal weiter wirklich
wahrheit unendlich einfach weil wir alle
wahrheit gesagt hat sagt was du willst
du musst dich getan aber ich denke
gerade für euch wie wärs wenn ihr den
ein lied vorsingen
du musst jetzt ein mariah carey und zwar
wenn er sich weigert bringt er zwei
stücke
das hat vorteile hätte themen wie kann
die stange aktuell ich mal reden ohne
alle drei sekunden zu husten sollte
jetzt so in maria carey vom regenschirm
spiel und drei stücke für den verlierer
strategie videospiele michael beginnt
das ist ein strategiespiel und spiel bei
dem der eine strategische planung ein
entscheidender faktor systems ein
und hören warum ich sagen es ist ein
einziges spiel was ich kenne allerdings
abgenommen hat
die mädels und verkauft muss es lesen
die fa cup ich frage doch ich kenne
keine spiele ich hätte keine gesperrt
ich musste arbeiten haben wird bleibt
die mehrheit gibt man dann gab's noch
sushi drei stücke für dich drei stücke
hier drei stücke für alle die den
sozialen bereich arbeiten unter
studieren trinken fünf lücke
max ist bespricht nur noch mit nike alle
dann einziger freund mike i gibt kelly
fünf euro beträgt 1 glas aus okay leute
das hier ist michaels glas lassen wir
sehen können wie viel noch drin ist habe
ich hier greifen für europa muss zu
action kann ist mit paper wäre man aber
gar nicht einschalten der mine größte
getroffen sobald das ist meins das ist
so mit sagt zwar greifen um das fest für
nicht gedacht dass man sich damit so was
muss dringend die ganze nacht suchte aus
ob schwarz oder weiß ich werfe schwarze
es gibt auch drei die hand 123
ich liebe halt haben die reflektieren
[Musik]
das brautpaar kraft dafür ihn warum sein
wir vertreten und zwar nicht so sehen
mehrheitsentscheidungen obwohl das muss
man auch mal sagen ich mag weil ich
nicht weiß an gale harold kreis ex-chef
der moment in dem man sich entspannen
kann weil man weiß dass es eben kennen
muss entscheiden wer von nike und max
ist bei der meinung nach am schnellsten
beleidigt diese person trinkt ja so
krass ausfällt muss danach war ich
angucken dann bin ich schon wieder max
lieber in den bergen ski fahren oder die
ferien am strand verbringt stimmt alle
gleichzeitig auch die verlierer dringend
vier stücke damals nicht verstanden oder
strahlen strand epd auf drei die hand ok
123 ja und trinkt zwei stücke werdet ihr
schon mal beim slow tanzen jemanden klar
gemacht hast ich glaube das muss auch so
sein wird slow dance das kommt dann mal
vor was ist los
die bahn also in alle die schon mal im
fernsehen waren trinken drei stücke
deutscher länder diese wurde sebastian
als auch max gesucht haben derjenige der
etwas wiederholt und nicht oder nicht
mehr weit bringt drei stücke beginn
dabei
zu sagen italien würde ich sozusagen bis
komplett schwarz auch unabhängig
voneinander dann machst du wenn spanien
jaja amerika deutschland fordern haben
wir schon eine bake ja doch in berlin
könnte sein ja ändern dass die griechen
recht nicht nur projektor schon okay
drei stücke für dich mal gibt das was
michael gewesen wie rumänien bocelli
trainings nur viele stücke wie du schon
gläser geleert hast null und das ist das
problem
rom wird also rum marken der jeder etwas
wiederholt oder nichts für weiß- creme-
und zwei stücke kelly beginnt morgen
hennessy cognac trinken wenn man mag es
verteilt sich viele stücke wie du
asiatische hauptstädte aufzählen kann
darauf waren wir willst aber verwirrten
trinks fünf stücke weil wir noch mal so
schlecht ich auch in erba bei
asiatischen eishockey
ich glaube ist da rein und hören denn
ihr konflikt ist sagt ja ja ja ja ich
stimme sicher ob ich halte mich gemacht
sagt doch einfach vom ist es mal auf
dieser erlaubnis aber hart kann schön
aber auch nicht wirklich
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher auf paging
hauptstadt ist oder hongkong hongkong
ist hongkong
das ist china hongkong hat die mega
unabhängigkeitsbewegung aber gehören
international china nicht die hauptstadt
weißt du was ist egal bei welcher stadt
ist eine bauliche hongkong eigenes lange
barenboims land glaube ich nicht ich
würde ich war mir sicher dass das ist
falsch aber trotzdem fünf stücke für
mich sebastian alle mit denen du nicht
bei snapshot befreien bis dringend zwei
stücke ja gut ich nur zeitweise
[Musik]
aber ich merke auch von leuten wie man
den ganzen tag und drehen
ich hab sie nicht mal seit elf stunden
oder so drehe ich videos brauchte das
körper wir brauchen alle die du musst
entscheiden wer vom markt ist der erste
der beiden der nackt durch den schnee
läuft volltrottel bringt zwei
gemeinsamkeiten zwischen marx und mike i
die person die keine ideen merkt oder
eine idee wiederholt trinkt vier stücke
sebastian beginnt guter erster anbieter
und wir beide hosten gäste gerne das
buch